for me the the real issue is to make
more opportunities for those who want to
really focus on science and less on an
academic career
each year at the lindau meetings in
Germany young researchers come together
to learn from Nobel Prize winners as
well as from each other
and working to understand some of the
fundamental processes that are involved
in many many cancers to define how
cancer will develop and how malignant
cancer cells will become I've been
designing materials that are able to
bind to radioactive atoms and then when
these materials are injected into the
bloodstream they specifically seek out
and bind to bone tumors the hoping that
this might be a new form of therapy for
a children's bone cancer but there's
much more to the meetings in lindau than
seeking scientific collaboration they
also inspire discussion about why
depressions in science
most scientists believe that the crucial
discoveries will come from the
universities they work in but Erich bet
six Nobel Prize came not from his
university research but from his working
industry I'm very excited to meet Eric
Betsy and to hear his perspective and
how he came up with this amazing
discovery of you know changing the way
that we think of microscopy and and the
barriers that that he has overcome and
I'm especially interested to hear how
him a leading academia in having this
very different perspective on science
has helped him to actually make this
discovery in the end so your talk had a
lot of biology images in it and your
background is in physics and you got the
Prize in Chemistry
so do you consider yourself a chemist or
a physicist or a tool builder ultimately
well I'm definitely not a chemist in any
way so when I learned about the prize in
Munich and then when I came home the
next day my group had made a big poster
with my face on it and said
congratulations Eric bet sig Nobel
laureate in chemistry and then it had a
quote from the interview that the Nobel
Foundation did with me the previous day
I know no chemistry right there's so
much serendipity that goes into these
discoveries and it was that also the
case for you did you feel like a
ridiculous degree oh really I think
there's an alternative universe not far
from here where I am an unemployed
mechanical engineer and it all fell into
place in about one month one month set
not just you know and I thought I
honestly thought I was going to be
stocking shelves in the Walmart three or
three months earlier you know that I had
completely blown you know all aspects of
my career but but it all fell in place
just like that I think a list of the
Nobel Prize winners before I came that
if you meet one you've got a note they
wonderful and some of them by reading
what it was I'd put them into one
category but they weren't actually
looked it was another category in
chemistry and on the other way the
super-resolution microscope this is all
physics
the super resolution microscope was what
Eric Betsy won his prize for he comes
from a very different perspective than
most academics and so I'm very
interested to hear what he thinks of the
future of research in academia for me
one of the problems is that the
university isn't necessarily it's a good
system for education but not necessarily
an optimal system for research the
skillset to be an assistant professor is
a different skill set than the skill set
to be a postdoc and some succeed at that
transition and some don't right what
would you change if you could wave a
magic wand remake academia I mean I
could rant for hours about that people
are ignorant of exactly how rewarding
these careers in industry and being and
how bright many of the people are in
industry that you work with and you know
there just needs to be greater
understanding of that as an alternative
to this sort of you know heartbreak of
banging your head against trying to get
and trying to get a tenure track
I thought Eric Betsy was an interesting
case because here's someone who
describes himself as a tool builder and
his background is physics and he's made
all these contributions to biology into
chemistry and I think it shows how when
you start from the foundation of one
discipline it's very easy to branch out
and solve really important problems even
when they don't occur within your
discipline and I think and he described
one of the ways that you actually came
up with discovery which was in an
interaction with biologists and
understanding what are some of the tools
that you've developed that can help me
solve the problems of physics and
chemistry but one thing that was also
very impressive was that he built his
microscope in his friend's living room
and so you don't necessarily need a
giant lab and all these fancy equipment
you just need your idea and the tenacity
to really go after it and to figure out
this problem that's
perhaps puzzled people for a very long
time
the beautiful bay above tree or Tree of
Life is an African icon the baobab fruit
contains four times the potassium of
banana three times the vitamin C of an
orange and twice the calcium of spinach
but the Bale Bob is an orphan science
has paid little attention to this tree
until now the African orphan crops
consortium is harnessing the power of
genetics for orphan crops the bail Bob
tree is the first of 101 plants to have
its genome sequence assembled and
annotated and the information will be
made available to all unrestricted where
millions of people are malnourished this
genetic data will help farmers provide
the food they need the genomes will
guide African plant breeders so they can
create crops that are higher yielding
water and nutrient use sufficient
resilient to climate change and full of
nutrition triggering a huge leap forward
for the diversity and sustainability of
the continents agriculture
you